it's good that you have good friends
they're like your brothers do you have
brothers no i don't i've always wanted
brothers uh but i'd uh i think i've
always have a sister have two sisters
yeah what what do they do one does
something with
something yeah someone does something
they attend business and another one
does another thing wow yeah i don't
really listen all that well like i my
sister just told me what she did but she
works for a company i'm sure she doesn't
want me to name the company but uh
do you find that the people around you
are really upset with you talking about
them
sometimes yeah oh yeah yeah yeah i can't
even mention what does she do in
entertainment uh she is an executive she
yeah she's an executive have you worked
with her uh no
you're asking or telling me i'm asking i
think i know would you not know your
sister if you were working with her no i
i no i don't know she i think i will be
working with her but i don't know she
works she i don't know i can't tell i
don't want to say it because like i talk
trash and people know our last names but
like she ran into my agent the other day
and one of my agents over at uta and she
was like oh i think my brother's over at
utah she's like who's your brother she's
like burke chrysler and she was like
hold on your brother's broke chrysler
she was like yeah she's like oh my hold
on so i think because i'm shirtless and
i drink a lot and i talk [ __ ] and i
you're incredibly successful i know but
i don't know if anyone wants to be
associated with me all the time oh i
think my daughter doesn't like my
daughter my daughter that's every
daughter though that's every yeah my
daughter didn't want doesn't i'm not
allowed to say where she wants to go to
college like she doesn't want to she
doesn't want to be she wants to go to
college i think she would change her
name if she could just to be regular i
didn't put his name on my applications
yeah yeah and what kind of it's
heartbreaking because you work so hard
to
build a career that you're proud of see
you know you don't know what it's like
to be a broke dad i remember being i was
talking about this last night with my
dad i remember being a broke dad going
to school a place called the sunshine
shack with georgia and isla and there
were successful dads there billy crudup
was a dad there ian gomez nia vardalos
like uh fred savage they were all dads
there now and uh jay chandrasekhar they
were all dads there and mom's there and
i remember going in there feeling like a
loser cause i because i would i would
watch everyone pull up in range rovers
and stuff and and then be like
and we wanted a good education so we
paid for it but i remember
it's crazy i wish i had known then what
i know now because i remember feeling
like a loser and then going for
christmas so you work hard so you can
establish a life for your kids so that
they can get all the things they want
and then you go to buy your daughter a
car for 16th birthday and she's like i
don't want that car i don't want to look
i'm not a rich kid dad and you're like
well no it's a good car and she's a
conversation
yeah and she's like i don't want that
i'm not driving to school in that
everyone's gonna be like oh great her
daddy bought her a
bmw and i'm like it's a great [ __ ]
car
that's what i think that's what happened
to us are you serious yeah it's exactly
you're talking about our lives i wanted
to pick up that's what georgia got yeah
i wanted to pick up and i bought her a
bmw and i was we live like parallel
lives i mean i i gotta this is insane it
isn't because i'm going through it all
right now oh and like and like you know
it gets easier i promise you just have
to wait it out do you want to hear
something really hilarious
so we would we do this trip
me and the girls are gonna do this trip
and and uh
and i
and i and i'm sitting with leanne and
i'm i had a drink and i said i'm gonna
i'm gonna
with george's and and either flying out
and i want to let them know it was when
i was doing red rocks as a matter of
fact right i said i want i'm going to
reach out to georgia and i want to let
her know that i'm trying harder that i
understand i'm frustrating i understand
my shortcomings i understand all of them
and that i will work harder to be a
better dad and that nothing's her fault
that it's it's me that i've created this
it's a very heartfelt
uh message
i'm crying at the end writing it right
and i'm like i go show delay and she
goes send it so i send to georgia in my
phone is saved as georgia my favorite
daughter that's what she saved her
number as i've since changed it oh
you have no idea we should we have the
fan she's a sister she always puts it
into my thing is my favorite daughter
i'm the favorite child i say yeah
because we have a son too he's right
there yeah but she always does that
this is insane it is insane so i send it
and i'm sitting by a creek
and i light a joint
and i'm relaxing in colorado i sent it
georgia's fine out the next day
and as soon as i send it
i look at my phone and i went wait
i think i sent that the wrong number
to the dead guy no oh i sent it to
there is a woman named georgia heart
stark who's got a podcast called my
favorite murder
and she's saved in my phone as georgia
my favorite murder
and she reads it and she replies i go
wrong wrong number i apologize
and then she writes back
i thought this was from my dad
she goes i'm crying right now i thought
this was from my dad
she's like just so you know it gets
better like i had problems with my dad
at that age listen she loves you it's
just it's just an awkward time and i'm
like
no i'm crying texting with you the wrong
georgia go inside
[Music]
you